welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and zack snyder's cut of justice
league is officially happening coming to
HBO max in 2021 which means the studios
are taken Brooke West yeah I'm gonna
explain how this came together but more
importantly what Snyder's for our movie
or 6 episode miniseries will look like
wake recap of course Zack Snyder
originally directed Justice League in
2016 2017 he assembled about a 4-hour
cut well it's just difficult for him
he's all about that bulk but he trimmed
it down to a 2 hour 20 minute rough cut
to screen for the studio but that cut
was unfinished there's no cut to release
technically chunks of the movie were
strung together with scratch audio goofy
placeholder animation it's the behind
the scenes stuff that audiences think
they want to see but if it were ever
released it would more likely be used to
mock all the potato animation and make
the cast look stupid unfortunately
Snyder had to step down in early 2017
due to a family tragedy the studio
replaced him with a vendor's director
Joss Whedon who we shot much of the film
filling it with quippy dialogue and new
sequences Justice League released in
November 2017 to mixed reviews and
mediocre box office performance and
Snyder fans unhappy with Whedon's recut
began using the hashtag-- release the
Snyder cut petition gained over a
hundred thousand signatures then we got
two years of rampant fan speculation
that was fanned by Zack Snyder himself
with concept art in hints of his vision
and overtime for many released the
Snyder cut kind of evolved to mean
finish the Snyder cut and then last
November Ben Affleck and gal gadot
joined the course of others like Snyder
and Jason Momoa and that got the
studio's attention so they met back with
Snyder in February of 2020 Snyder
pitched to them a recut of his existing
material to release on HBO max and
rather than just a four-hour movie
Snyder conceived of a six-part
miniseries of episodes and cliffhangers
sources say he initially wanted reshoots
with the actors of the studio said no
they limited him to a twenty to thirty
million dollar budget that would cover
post-production Reese coring VFX and ADR
meaning the actors like that Affleck or
Henry Cavill could record new dialogue
to dub over scenes
Snyder dropped this news last week
saying that we have only seen one-fourth
of the footage that he shot for the
movie so how will Zack Snyder
reconfigure his hours
unseen material into six episodes for
HBO max next year so before we continue
losing your hair it's a bummer
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35 we don't want that
we want the hair on our head to never
age we've keeps it's easier and more
affordable to get treatment for your
hair loss may help you keep the hair
that you have keeps offers generic
versions of the only two fda-approved
hair loss products out there but at half
the cost of your local pharmacy and you
don't have to go to a doctor's office
you can do it all from home where you're
probably stuck right now you meet with a
doctor online and they ship the
treatment right to your home
find out why keep says more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors and
nearly a hundred thousand benchrest
cubes for their hair loss prevention
medication so if you're noticing that
you're losing your hair do something
about it for a limited time just go to
keeps calm / new rock stars or click on
the link in the description to receive
50% off your first order
Snyder's original ending for Justice
League was going to be like everything
this guy touches much darker the villain
Steppenwolf gets gored by Aquaman's
Trident and then Wonder Woman
decapitates him then a boob tube opens
up in Steppenwolf's and rolls down it
stopped in at the feet of the real
villain pulling the strings Darkseid
according to some descriptions stomped
the skull and promised to return
Darkseid is the DC space deity created
by Jack Kirby Darkseid actually preceded
and influenced Thanos ed marvel he comes
from the held planet of apocalypse
Steppenwolf is this uncle so these
Snyder cuts will explore Darkseid
backstory the first act of his cut
featured a scene detailing Darkseid's
involvement with that ancient war with
the Amazonians
with Darkseid originally fought under
the name access his mother Hagrid spirit
was encased in those three mother boxes
that they're seeking on earth explaining
why they're so important to them and why
they're called mother boxes now we'll
explore how Darkseid's role in this
Snyder cut would have set up the DC EU
and how if this HBO mech series is a hit
the studio might try to extend his
vision into Justice League - that's
coming in the next rogue theory episode
keep an eye out for it now we will also
further explore the nightmare future in
dark Superman from Batman V Superman
Snyder's cut included a vision from
cyborg during Superman's resurrection
revisiting that post-apocalyptic future
this is going to be based on elements
from
injustice gods among us in which
Darkseid carries out his anti-life
equation to control all the minds in the
universe
remember there's that moment when the
flash spoke to Bruce through that time
vortex to Batman V Superman and he said
sounds like the plan was for Lois Lane
to die when Darkseid boom tubes into the
Batcave setting up Superman to snap go
dark and help Darkseid conquer the
planet
there was a deleted scene released with
the Justice League digital HD release
showing Clark walking through his
Kryptonian chamber and passing a black
Superman suit check whether or not
Snyder shot a fuller version of cavil in
the dark suit this is something that
could probably be accomplished with the
effects if George Lucas could turn r2d2
from blue to black in 1977 they can
definitely do it with Superman now so
the death of Lois Lane black Superman
suit injustice anti-life equation this
future is the dart promise of Zack
Snyder's DC EU that I think he is most
eager to share and we are most eager to
watch okay another Zack Snyder plot
thread Green Lantern in the Martian
Manhunter the theatrical cuts post
reddit scenes were the rise of the
injustice league with Deathstroke and
Lex Luthor and of course the flash
Superman race Joe Manganiello hinted
that there was more to his scene that
was removed and other rumors have
suggested Deathstroke scenes in Gotham
maybe with Batman Gordon in Lex in
Arkham Asylum but if you remember Zack
Snyder's original tagline for Justice
League was unite the seven suggesting we
would get seven Justice League members
in this film but we only got six there
was no Green Lantern or Martian
Manhunter but then last year Snyder
revealed that Harry linux's character
general Swanwick was actually Martian
Manhunter in disguise and that he knew
Clark was Superman Linux has recently
tweeted suggesting that dual role could
be revealed on screen also an unnamed
VFX artist couple years ago slamed there
was a post-credits scene with Bruce
being awoken by a green light in his
lakeside mansion visited by Green
Lantern Corps members Tom RA and Kilowog
who warned him about Darkseid and maybe
set up a future of a Green Lantern Corps
film that could tie into the future
sequels the actors Sam Benjamin claims
to have shot a scene for the movie
leading some to speculate that he could
have been playing Green Lantern Hal
Jordan but it sounds like he was a
soldier in the heroes
sequence now the Schneider cut appears
to also include more with a character
cyborg Victor stone Snyder said he
called up ray Fisher with the news and
he was stoked we will see him before the
accident playing football so we saw in
the trailer and an extended sequence
with his father Silas stone at STAR Labs
with Batman breaking into STAR Labs
during the Superman resurrection plot
and here it sounds like we will meet dr.
Choi we've seen in pictures
aka Atum setting him up in the DCU
and according to Schneider cyborg will
see his father die now there's also
reportedly an alternate version of
Wonder Woman's rescue scene in which she
fails to fling that bomb high enough to
save the kids and tourists can imagine
how that [ __ ] would have been way too
dark for Whedon who came from a
cinematic universe with an insanely low
three hundred casualties across three
citywide destroying events zack snyder's
like 300 i made a movie about that way
more diyanet perhaps this dark moment
would set up Diana's blood thirst in
decapitating Steppenwolf sounds like
Barry Allen had alternate Snyder
cutscenes including him saving iris West
from car accident and just reportedly
being less of a wide-eyed noob who
spends movie motorboating Diana other
changes it sounds like the budget is
also for Reese coring the film I mean we
might hear less of Danny Elfman's
updated score and more of junkie XL
original music reports suggests there
will be more scenes with Jeremy Irons is
Alfred like that mom over in the trailer
that was left out of the theatrical cut
you said you'd come no that's hope
you're not too late as well as Aquaman
with Willem Dafoe is volcko meanwhile
Whedon's reshoot editions like the
russian family
Batman's opening rooftop fights and that
new Henry Cavill footage with the CGI
upper lip that might all be removed in
the Snyder cut look I'm a nerd who loves
to see every deleted scene an alternate
ending of every movie so I am thrilled
Zack Snyder will get to complete his
vision but he raced the word Joss Whedon
did he's another writer and filmmaker
who I deeply admire and anyone worried
this sets a precedent that forever
dissatisfied fans can demand an eerie
cut via hashtag and I won't get too
worked up that Game of Thrones petition
has 10 times of signatures as a sniper
cut one did an HBO told them to [ __ ] off
join our official discord for weekly
watch Long's and past films you can
actually vote to make the next series of
DC EU rewatch if you want it by becoming
a patreon of new rock stars at
patreon.com slash
rock stars follow me on Instagram and
Twitter a TA vos followed new rock stars
and subscribe for breakdowns of
everything you love
thanks for watching bike
[Music]